and on Tuesday so it's time for the
history of the world to begin the
discourse is one that I haven't taught
before and to the best of my knowledge
no one else at Columbia has taught it
before because world history has
generally been regarded as a subject
that either cannot or should be taught
at elite universities it it has been a
very unusual area of history in that
instead of deriving from the thought and
writings of famous historians it has
emerged from the ground up from
essentially it's a demand-side course
that comes out of the K through 12
educational system and I need to tell
you a little bit about how that occurred
in order for you to understand how I'll
approach this course during the 60s and
the 70s you all know enough about
history to know that we had a profoundly
transforming civil rights movement
accompanied and even more followed by a
feminist movement along with a very
strong increased awareness of the role
of Native Americans and immigrant groups
from non-european backgrounds
and the result of this educationally was
that in the in the school systems both
college but even more pre-college it
became understood that American history
should be taught as a history that
embodies that embodies diversity now
that provoked a certain opposition of
people who said that multiculturalism is
somehow a betrayal of American values
and and principles but by and large a
multicultural or diversity oriented
narrative of American history became the
standard in the American school systems
to a lesser degree in other parts of the
world to a much lesser degree the the
problem was that if you went back and
taught American history this way how far
back could you go you could go back to
1776 you could go back and maybe do a
century of colonial American history but
there's a problem that if you wanted to
get the earlier take on history that
would meld with the new ways of teaching
American history you are going to have
to have a narrative that manifested the
same degree of diversity or of say
cultural relativism or at least
appreciation of different cultures that
you had for the new American history
courses and yet the way history was
taught is that Western Civ was the broad
context within which American history is
placed and Western Civ was a
narrative constructed in a very innocent
artificial fashion starting from Egypt
to Mesopotamia migrating to Greece
migrating to Europe forgetting Ethiopia
forgetting Egypt and Mesopotamia in
Greece becoming the Roman Empire
becoming the Dark Ages becoming the
Renaissance the Reformation early modern
period the sural revolution and us so
you had a master narrative of the of how
Europe got to be Europe that was just
fine as a preamble for American history
so long as the only Americans you're
interested in teaching were white
Americans of European background so now
you had a problem that you had a you had
a history that was developing for for
American history courses in a diverse
fashion coming on top of a broader
history that was Eurocentric and Europe
well not exclusively Eurocentric because
Egypt and Mesopotamia are not in Europe
but we forget about Egypt Mesopotamia
once we get the Greeks revved up and
going
so we had a Eurocentric history that
didn't match the American history so the
result was that various educators in
various states started to agitate for
global awareness or global studies and
in the course of time you know 20 or 30
states mandated that global studies of
some sort be taught so that there was
some kind of a of a linkage between the
way American history was being rethought
and the way history broadly was
this job went initially to social
studies teachers who had been around for
several generations usually taught in
elementary schools and now they were
charged with global studies and that a
problem developed because social studies
teachers tended to have a chronological
depth of about 10 years and so they
couldn't do that part of history that
would dovetail with the early stages of
American history so a sort of a coup
came about in the 1980s in which high
school history teachers fought with and
succeeded in grasping from the social
studies teaching Network the teaching of
world history
now these history teachers were teachers
of American history and of Western Civ
none of them had ever taken world
history but it was a kind of a turf war
they said we're historians we deal with
the past you want to do the past
differently you go through us you don't
go hire somebody else now we do the
history and so they kicked the social
studies teachers out I may be
exaggerating and now it became the job
of history teachers particularly in high
school to to carry out the state
mandates for global awareness Global
Studies and so forth now the problem was
that none of the people who were now
going to teach world history had ever
taken world history because world
history wasn't taught in American
universities
I remember the 90s going to you know
seminars on how to teach world history
in which you might have a hundred high
school teachers and if you took a show
of hands you know how many of you were
teaching world history and they'd all
raise their hand and say how many of you
have taken world history and no one
would raise their hand and this was a
terrible problem because you had people
who had no qualifications to teach world
history who are now teaching it by
mandate and they were struggling just to
say the least and we're talking about
10,000 plus teachers nationwide who had
to do this in addition to coaching the
soccer team or whatever else they were
expected to do this was seen as a crisis
by certain organizations the College
Board brought together a workshop of
senior historians and high school
teachers to talk about how to do it the
National Council of the humanities
funded a project to create a master
outline for world history involving I
think eight senior professors of history
none of whom either taught or had
studied world history the meetings of
the committee were essentially turf wars
you know we need more in China no no we
need more India and so forth we never
would have finished the job
if our professor of Japanese history had
not been absent on the last day because
she was not going to give up any turf to
the rest of us so you had national
standards for world history you had a
report by the College Board you had the
Educational Testing Service which is an
offshoot of the College Board created an
AP exam in world history
and the AP exam had a division a
chronological division said here is how
world history should be taught the AP
exam had a massive impact the rat most
rapidly growing field for AP examination
that the Educational Testing Service had
ever known
you know thousands upon thousands of
students were taking world history in
tenth grade taking the advanced
placement exam in 11th grade and and
then blowing off their senior year in
language college this was a profound
challenge for the textbook industry
which quite openly did not pay any
attention whatsoever to what any of
these well-intentioned committees were
trying to do the textbook industry had a
huge investment in producing Western Civ
textbooks and now their market was being
challenged so what they did initially
was to take a Western Civ book and pay
somebody to write an additional chapter
in India a chapter in China chapter and
Africa chapter on something else and so
you've got not Western Civ light but a
Western Civ heavy where you took your
the same there to be had and you added
these things to it and it really worked
well as a reinforcement of imperialism
to show that Europe always was and
always will be the center and other
parts of the world are peripheral areas
to to Europe and it became very clear
that that the Augmented Western Civ
approach was going to be a failure
too much western civ and indeed the
project of world history became pretty
explicitly defined by the end of the 80s
as a project of provincial of provincial
izing europe and provincial izing the
United States now they could do it they
could provincial eyes United States that
is to say right a world history in which
the United States plays very little role
because they knew that there was another
course entirely on American history and
therefore nobody could criticize them
for for soft-pedaling the American side
of it or provincial izing Europe was a
huge problem universities like this one
and most others they gave PhD degrees
had industry departments that were
divided into American Historians
frequently a majority or if in the South
Civil War historians and maybe a
majority but American Historians
European historians and other or what we
call here Columbia we say we have the
Americanists European s and the world
and the world group was often thought of
as being of the parallel of the American
as the European us except a little bit
smaller because they just had to cover
Asia Africa a Senate Center so so they
were you know that the investment in
Western Civ was colossal
professorships scholarship of every
variety publishing companies you could
not abandon
Western Civ without without a fight
overtime Eurocentrism as a Bugaboo was
joined by sino centrism because the
Chinese historians had a record of
archival resources and documents and
scholarly effort and so forth that made
them say ok let's do the world the way
it should be namely Europe and China and
so you ended up with the idea that world
historians should be should avoid
Eurocentrism and avoid sino centrism or
indeed avoid any centrism and that is
the reason that I maintain that that
this course which is our first on world
history will be eccentric it's also
built into the fact that this is my last
year teaching before retirement and I
can say anything I damn well please with
no consequences you know no regrets so
you know some of you will look back and
say he seems really eccentric but he
didn't say is going to be all
but you know you'll find out the so so
this was an interesting case you had a
world history being taught in the
schools and then you had a sort of
second and third-tier public colleges
you know state universities community
colleges who felt we have to teach the
high school teachers who teach world
history so they started to offer world
history so that their graduates could
have some background when they went to
got a job teaching high school well it
turned out their professors had no
background in world history so then
there's a thought well maybe the
universities that produce PhDs
should teach people to teach
people to teach world history and very
gradually world history has gone from
being in the schools and worked its way
up to being now at Columbia
I don't think Harvard teaches this I'm
pretty sure Princeton doesn't but and if
they may not do it after this year who
knows but it's a it's a fascinating
example of the way in which history is
built not on just intellectual
achievement or vision but also on
matters of politics and ideology this is
a course that is heavily rooted in
issues of politics and ideology every
year in the summer this past year was in
Fort Collins Colorado hundreds of
teachers gather for a week or two to
grade the AP exams this year was eight
hundred and seventy high school teachers
throughout Colorado and I think they had
to do several grades several hundred
exams apiece and a close friend of mine
I've known people who have done it I
haven't done it never will but my
friends had you know it was like a cult
these people live world history they
look down on other forms of history
world history is is what it is and yet
there's no real clarity as to what world
history actually is so to some degree
it's an ideology if you had to define it
as an ideology as a philosophy in my
view what I'd say is that world history
in the way that it is being thought of
by people who identify themselves as
world historians of members of the World
History Association which unlike other
academic associate
patience is about 50% high school
teachers and 50% college professors what
they are doing they might define as the
antidote to the Columbia core curriculum
now for last 80 years or so we have had
a core curriculum at Columbia that has
assumed a certain quasi divine quality
for the Western civilization
accomplishment at its highest level and
we we teach that in CC and litt hum our
tongue music hum all of these are worthy
courses I have no objection to the
Columbia core curriculum in fact I'm the
only member of the faculty is actually
taught all four of those courses and yet
there is no way that you can tweak the
Columbia core curriculum to include the
rest of the world
you cannot say oh this year we're going
to include even khaldoun or you know a
passage from Mencius or Gilgamesh and
therefore we have the whole world
covered because your standard of
comparison remains the Western Civ Core
beyond that the structure of the
Columbia core curriculum assumes that
the proper way to study cultures over
time is through literary tax or artistic
monuments of one sort or another in
other words the the core curriculum is
strongly biased against popular history
social history economic history
quantitative history all these areas
that do not depend upon the great works
we have the the conceit that that
there's a sort of conversation among all
the great thinkers that you know you can
sit in class and imagine what
would st. Augustine say to Martin Luther
or John Rawls or something like that
notes total baloney but it's it's the
conceit that keeps the thing going that
you imagine that this is a great
conversation world history tends to
avoid the the peaks of high culture both
because they're trying to D Center the
narrative and get it away from Europe
and because the problem with any high
cultural text is that in an American
school system people are always looking
for the European analog you know what is
the bhagavad-gita like in Western
history what are the analog Analects of
Confucius like and so forth so the world
historians tend to use different
principles than the people who who
designed and you know devoted their
careers to things like the Columbia core
curriculum nowadays we have a lot of
debate over the core curriculum about
how to and whether to tweak it to be
international and my own view is that
that cannot work and that you have to
actually move out of that house and
moved into into another one maybe that
one's made of bricks and this one's made
of twigs nevertheless we're moving with
the piggies into a different house in a
course like this so what do we do in a
course like this on the first place
there are three different levels at
which you can think about world history
and to some degree I want to use this
course to to introduce all three the
first is as a narrative
when you finish this course particularly
to take both semesters you will know
everything that happened of importance
in the entire history of the world and
you know mines will drop out of college
after that because what more is there to
know actually that won't happen the
problem is that the narrative is a
colossal grand compromise that comes out
of the whole history of curriculum
design a combined with the interests of
textbook publishers what distinguished
world history from American history was
that everyone could assume that a high
school teacher teaching American history
actually knew something about American
history before the course began and
could read a textbook and sort of
understand it and augment it through
their own additional reading and
experience the opposite sumption was the
true world history the assumption was
that the teacher knows nothing and
everything must be in the textbook this
put enormous power in the hands of the
textbook publishers and the textbook
publishers have progressively abandoned
the Western Civ augmented approach and
adopted a sort of a pan global
perspective that tries to give balance
to all parts and all periods this has
not been wildly successful educationally
but it is phenomenally successful if
you're lucky enough to be an author I
happen to be lucky enough to be an
author and
it has allowed me to to lead a life over
the last 10 years or so very different
from what my Columbia salary would have
permitted because the teachers are so
dependent on the textbook so if you have
a successful textbook you to you sell
many many thousands of book units and
you fight off your competition you
struggle for market share and so forth
and so on very tedious but fortunately
very lucrative and one of the things
that you discover is that when you write
this narrative you're not writing
history in the way you would if you were
writing a monograph on say the climate
history of Iran and the Oh in the 11th
century which is what my most recent
monographic work has been on nobody
expects you to have anything new they
expect you to be artful in putting
together things that are generally
agreed upon and broadly known in the
textbook race the victory goes to the
fastest horse not to the fastest animal
you cannot enter a text book that looks
like a cheetah because you will be seen
as cheating and it has to look like a
horse and smell like a horse and run
like a horse in order to be accepted so
the result is that all the publishers
read each other's publications sample
the views of adopters and potential
adopters and they gradually focus in on
certain ways of doing it the result is
that even though this field is less than
20 years old in the way I'm describing
it it's become prematurely ossified now
the books all say more or less the same
thing but what they're saying really
isn't any more world history than
and it's a it's a new construction of
history that is not the old Eurocentric
history but it isn't really a world
history in the way that a world history
might be done by people who are more
adventurous and yet this is the way we
teach it this is the way the Educational
Testing Service designs the exam that is
the way I'm going to other readings in
this in this course for this semester
we're going to read this book this is
volume 1 of the earth and it's people's
authored by me and several colleagues
this is my effort to profiteer off the
class and we will read one chapter a
week this is the way it's designed for
the 14 weeks of the semester I do not
expect you to learn any of the material
contained in the book the exams will not
ask you for any factual material I don't
expect you to memorize anything in the
book I'm going to be asking you to do
something that is much harder than say
think about what's in the book and be
prepared on papers and exams to to to
raise questions to deconstruct it to to
suggest ways in which it's you know it's
ridiculous the model for how to
demonstrate the ridiculousness of it
will be my lectures other words the
lectures for this course will be a
second level of history let's say we'll
have a narrative containing a book and
then we'll have a course of lectures
that is kibbutzim the book I know every
debate that has gone into this book I
have been the principal or author or
a editorial rewriter on every chapter in
the book I know where we left things out
and why where we put things in that
didn't belong and why where we made
compromises that were undesirable and so
I'm going to talk about the problems
with constructing world yesterday's
narrative the third level is going to
take place in sections in this class
undergraduates will be offered a choice
of four sections starting on the the
section times and places will be handed
out on Thursday and the first sections
will be held next week and the sections
will discuss the material generally
speaking the material in the chapter
from the week before our graduate
students will be in a section with me
that will meet on Thursday from 10 to
10:50 tentatively in my office in
upstairs in room 421 depending on how
many graduate students there are the TAS
will will talk not only about what's
been in the material for in the textbook
for the week and perhaps give their
version of what was wrong with lectures
but they will also talk about and ask
you to discuss ancillary readings of
which there won't be a lot but also
material contained on a website called
bridging world history this was a very
large and expensive project by the
Annenberg foundation that produced units
covering themes of world history and
certain themes these are videos plus
transcripts plus visual materials and so
forth and certain units will be matched
with specific chapters and specific
weeks and you'll be expected to look at
them and be able to to to talk about
them it is not inconceivable that for a
paper or an examination that one would
use you know or involve one of the units
from ridging world history that is not
assigned in the course this is not
simply a matter to try and produce
history light it is also an effort to to
come to to grips with the fact that we
are rapidly moving into an a teaching
environment at all levels in which
written materials have no intrinsic
priority over materials in some other in
some other medium what is distinctive
about the bridging world history is that
the unlike the narrative which is
diachronic that is to say it moves along
progressively in time the the units in
bridging world history are thematic and
they will compare things from different
periods in different parts of the world
according to a certain theme like a
religious proselytization or you know
spread of writing systems or something
like that there will be no expectation
that you go into program logic Ronna
logical progression and in fact you can
look at those units in any order in any
order you like but I'm going to try and
match them to specific chapters because
this embodies one of the great puzzles
of the world history field should world
history be chronological and if not what
are the alternatives
all of the books that exist as
narratives world history are
chronological they start early and they
ordinarily manifest a certain crescendo
as you get closer to to modern times
there is the conceit that history moves
faster as you go along further in time I
don't think anybody who thinks about
that really believes it there are
certainly types of change that occur
more rapidly in certain areas but to say
that history moves faster is to imply
that history is something that moves as
opposed to simply the aggregate of what
humans have done over some thousands or
tens of thousands of years to the degree
that these can be recovered from
surviving materials but nevertheless of
the textbooks tend to move in a
crescendo fashion so the AP course
usually acquires that the second
semester started in 1500 AD while the
first scene first semester starts in
about 8000 BC
so we have ninety five hundred years of
her one semester followed by a semester
with five hundred years there's a
problem you know there any reason why
that should be now in addition to the
theory that history moves faster you
have people who will look at him and say
history is proportional to the number of
humans living and the population
increases since 1500 have been so
gargantuan compared with the slow growth
of population prior to that time that
you can in justify it on that basis
because if it is the aggregate of human
experiences there are more humans who
have experiences that can be aggregated
so you can make excuses for for this
chronological crescendo and yet the
tendency is to to on the one hand
minimize what happened before 1500 on
the other hand to give the historians
who focus on the pre 1500 period a
chance to wield their brush very broadly
while the ones after 1500 are expected
to actually pay closer attention to
facts now
there are certain people who are will
become famous as world historians like
Oswald Spengler or Arnold Toynbee in the
20th century HG Wells you go back
farther you get Hegel back farther you
get even called une but the history
books that we have now really don't come
from that from that intellectual line as
I say they have come up from from more
practical considerations in the k-12
system so let's notice this issue of how
do you prevent eyes Europe it isn't
simply a matter of saying less about
Europe although that's certainly part of
it it's also a matter of of asking
question is Europe special in any way
other than the fact that we know a lot
about it in other words is the narrative
of Europe absolutely distinctive or is
it simply the one we know best
certainly in the post-world War two
period we had a kind of climax of
of several centuries of world of
European triumphalism that Europe and
it's American you know sidekick
they now ruled the entire world and they
believed very firmly particularly the
United States particularly the 1960s
that the entire world was destined to
become like America in a process known
as modernization modernization Theory
became the technique for approaching
non-european parts of the world or
non-western parts as they were called
why the word West is used is why anyone
would say Europe is Western civilization
when we are so far west of Europe when
we say America's Western civilization in
Europe as Eastern yeah
oriental but we don't so the the
modernization theory was climaxing in
the decade when the European empires
were collapsing and by the 1980s it
became clear to pretty much everyone
that somehow the model of Europe as
being the exemplar of where the whole
world was going to go was not quite
working out and now you have people who
are saying suggesting that maybe China
is the exemplar of where the whole world
will go just as in the 1970s you had
some people were saying that Japan might
be exactly exemplar of where the world
will go maybe we will still reach the
point where we can say that Iran is the
exemplar where the world will go my
favorite but the thing is there is no
for all the world to go 2-1 into one
place and this is one of the things that
that gets troublesome in world history
do you look at the world as converging
and here the current word globalization
embodies this notion that there's a
convergence or you to say or do you say
that there has always been a shifting
pattern of dominance and a ever
refreshing current of diversity and that
it's never going to come together
there's fundamentally a philosophical
issue or an economic one whatever the
distinction is between those the if you
try to look at it more broadly one way
of doing it is to say that are there
common denominators although differently
I would say there are common
denominators there are aspects of human
experience and behavior that are common
to every society at every period of
history in every part of the world and
if you focus on common denominators you
cannot end up with a centrism because
those those currents those forces those
manifestations of the human experience
will will still be there so what would
common denominators be the ones that are
built into this book that you'll see are
to one or
to some degree to two sub degree for one
of them is called environment and
Technology every human society has seen
human groups coping with environmental
problems or opportunities and
deploying inventing and deploying or
discovering technologies to make this
possible so one of the themes we have is
ent environment and technology another
one we have is called diversity and
dominance it's originally called
dominance and diversity and then it was
felt that that was a little too
heavy-handed so we switched it around to
diversity and dominance and said that
all societies have some pattern of
ranking or domination but you never have
total uniformity you always have
diversity manifested in one way or
another now the reason for these themes
this was inside the first world history
book that that adopted a thematic
approach and this has made us the target
of numerous other heavily-armed
textbook writing teams that are trying
to to destroy bullet they haven't
succeeded yet but but themes proved to
be a fairly viable approach as opposed
for example to an opposing version which
relates to convergence which is contact
where you say world history is the story
of when societies come into contact so
it's a story of travelers and traders
conquerors and explorers yeah but that
gets pretty boring and the complaint by
most historians was that why should we
only look at Marco Polo and leave out
the rest of the Renaissance you know why
is it that only the traveler and the
trader and the Explorer so forth why do
they get special mention so the contact
approach which is favored by some of my
colleagues in the world history field
notably Ross done out in San Diego I
don't think has been as successful as
the thematic approach
but the thing is there are common
denominators that don't lend themselves
to to writing for example you can say
spirituality is a common denominator
human groups as far as we can tell have
some orientation toward toward
spirituality the problem is that they
are very inconsistent in their
preservation of evidence about that and
the same thing would be true of let's
say rhythm you know humans understand
the beat line Oh some we don't but you
know but and the rhythms differ but we
don't have any any data that are going
to to give us this you talk to dance
historians and they're incredibly
frustrated in trying to push the history
of dance back they can see the history
of dance at the the upper end you know
what what survives now but knowing where
it was five hundred years ago is
extremely difficult to do art history
art history is a little bit better but
again it depends upon the what things
have been have survived what materials
they were they dealt with and so forth
audio-visual resources like those in
bridging world history to some degree
permit a an expansion of the sorts of
common denominators that that you know I
think are make it possible to compare
societies across time and space the
particular common denominator that I
have developed as my hobby horse has
been relations with animals human
societies always have some sort of
attitude toward the natural world and
particularly the world of animals
presumably they have attitudes toward
plants as well not only yeah but what
can you say about that so I have written
a book entitled hunters herders and
hamburgers it was the product of a
course I taught here for many years
entitled domestic animals in human
history it was a book that was intended
to transform animal history with
brilliant new theses it was a total
failure
partly because while I described the
existence of the animal rights movement
I did not endorse it so the animal
rights people said what you're not out
there you know freeing minks why write
about animals at all so so the book is
there and I'm actually that'll be the
first reading that I'll ask you to do
which is a segment from several chapters
from hunters herders and hamburgers that
will be available on course works is
available now it's available now and it
has to do with with the beginnings of of
domestication
how did domestic animals come into being
there is a an enormous literature in
this subject in which there is great
controversy and very little agreement
which is to say there are lots of people
who disagree with me which is a fault
but what can I do so that you know
animals will come up again and again in
this course technology will come up
again and again because I've taught
history of Technology here so to some
degree the lectures will be will lean
toward the things that I know most about
now let me move to a substantive
question it has to do with where does it
start the you know because we have a
word prehistory we have a philosophical
presumption that history starts
otherwise we couldn't have something
that comes before it the problem with
this is that when the word prehistory
gained circulation the history
profession seemed to believe fairly
uniformly that history depended upon
written records that therefore
prehistory was what happened before you
had written records there isn't anyone
in the historical profession today
that would really maintain this
definition against all comers partly
because of the amazing discoveries made
by archaeologists partly because of
increased scientific ability to analyze
material remains and partly because
Africa and Latin America or
pre-columbian America don't have
anything like a trove of early written
materials
and yep you know you can't leave them
out and therefore how do you do how do
you do that history so so the question
of where history starts begins to be
debated there let's say the the classic
starting point was the first
civilizations supposed to be in river
valleys in the Middle East this is
probably not true but this is where it
started because that's where we got the
first written materials Mesopotamia in
Egypt
well maybe not but that's where it
appeared that we got the first written
materials then we move toward the idea
of well maybe it's the Neolithic
Revolution and the beginning of
domesticated plants and animals that's a
starting point which in the Middle East
is around 8000 BC problem is that you
can have domesticated plants without
mosquito animals investigated animals
without domesticated plants and there is
very very little relationship between
the processes that seem to lead to the
domestication of plants the process is a
contribute to the domestication of
animals but they're they're lumped
together in this thing and we call the
Neolithic Revolution which technically
is this is defined as pre metallic
archaeological sites that have hundreds
and thousands of itty-bitty chips of
Flint and the
the Flint or other stone was set in a
sickle so you would have a piece of wood
shaped roughly like that and then you
would embed in it these sharp stone
chips and you would use this sawtooth
like device to cut grass you'll go into
a field of wild wheat or al barley put
your arm around a whole bunch of stalks
and you'd sawed through them and the the
residue of the grass can be found on the
chips that survive today we know that
this was done so we say okay with it
this is Neolithic we know that we can
attach these little bits of stone to the
growing of of grasses that become
domestic what this has to do with
animals is you know is purely conjecture
because there was a theory that is still
hotly debated that the best Gatien of
animals depends upon sedentary life
because the animals have to be kept in a
pen and how are you going to pen up the
animals if you're traveling around every
night so if you have to have sedentary
life then you have to have something
you're living on therefore you have to
have something like domesticated plants
this was a this notion of penning up the
animals to begin a process of
Investigation and I'll go into this in
more detail on Thursday this was a
successor theory to the theory that
hunters became herders so that people
let's say in Central Asia for safe and
the Mesolithic on they hunted horses and
ate them and then just about the time
some people somewhere else we're
planting wheat and barley they said
let's stop hunting the horses and let's
start hurting them instead and voila
domestic horses they simply evolved and
then you think well why didn't they do
that ten thousand years earlier wasn't
that a stupid thing to wait so long I
said well they didn't know domestication
existed well of course they did because
they had dogs well you know maybe they
just didn't maybe they thought about the
dogs differently than horses it became
very confusing but the Neolithic
Revolution becomes this hypothetical
starting point then you have something
that has arisen in the last five years
or so which is called big history and
it's their books on it their debates on
it and big history says why is it that
if we've had hominids around for 3
million years
why are we only writing the history of
them for the last ten thousand years
from 8000 BC to the present what about
those other millions hundreds of
thousands of years
shouldn't we write that as part of our
history and so the big history people
say let's think of all of the hominids
and people you know how human like
beings existed and think of them all
together and then you think and you
think and you think and
no you realize that you're not going to
get anywhere so you leave the bathroom
and you go back to your office and you
try and do some real history but the the
problem with big history is that it it
encourages people to really get involved
with the science because this you know
for the pre Neolithic stuff it's really
complicated science to understand how to
interpret the things you're looking at
and the science changes over time just
take one small but perhaps telling
example dating with carbon-14 carbon-14
is a naturally occurring isotope of
carbon that is taken in by plants and
animals and there the carbon oxygen
cycle and so the percentage of carbon-14
in your body at any one moment is
considered to be equivalent to the
percentage of carbon-14 that you have in
the atmosphere at large so you get a
ratio between carbon-14 which decays
into carbon-12 the rate of decay is
known and therefore when you look at
organic remains from long ago and you
look at the ratio of carbon 14 to carbon
12 you can say there must have been so
much carbon-14 and now it is diminished
and therefore we can measure them out of
time so the amount of carbon-14 becomes
a dating device this was a great
breakthrough in archeology
and it proved to be only partially
correct because the assumption was that
the percentage of the carbon in the
atmosphere that was of the isotope
carbon-14 was not a constant but rather
changes over time and this was
determined by studying the wood
contained in tree rings so that every
ring in a tree the the wood stops
absorbing carbon after that season and
the next ring out the next ring out and
so you could look at a sequence of
carbon-14 in tree rings and by matching
tree-ring thicknesses you could push
back thousands of years and so you came
up with something called corrected
carbon 14 dates the corrected dates tend
to be much older than the straight
carbon 14 dates depending on how fact
far back you go in time now this this
could have consequences for example if
you look at carbon 14 dates and you
think of Stonehenge and you say well you
know if you go to Greece you take a tour
and you go to Mycenae and you go to a
tomb there where you see the stone work
that's been done or you go to Terrans
and you see the stone work done there
then you look at Stonehenge you and you
look at the carbon 14 dates you say well
the Greeks who had domestic animals and
wheat and barley built in big stones and
somewhat later you had big stones
showing up in France and Scotland and
England so the Greeks must have come and
taught the people to schlep big stones
around
why they would have done this is unclear
except presumably that the Greeks knew
that moving big stones was what
civilized people did then corrected
carbon 14 dates came in and it turned
out the Stonehenge was older than the
earliest big stones in Greece so then
people had to say well none of us
believed that the English went to Greece
and taught them how to schlep big stones
because that would make no sense at all
because the Greeks are civilized and you
know in England they were living in
caves so instead we have to think of
some way that those stones could have
been moved without the assistance of
some smart Greek now we've known this
for some time and the issue of carbon 14
dates as opposed to corrected carbon 14
dates is an important one I'll come back
to it later on when I talk about the
invention of the wheel which is a
crucial topic that I will bore you with
of some length but turns out that now we
look further at carbon-14 and we find
you know there are sites where the
carbon-14 level in animal bones is
different from the carbon-14 level in
human bones as if you had three hundred
year old people who were hurting
six-month-old sheep you know it didn't
make much sense why would you have a
difference in the bones and the answer
that turns out so far as I can read I'm
not a chemist to have to do with the
issue of nitrogen 15 who knew the
nitrogen 15 is conveyed into human
skeletal remains by the consumption of
fish because fish
you know have a high levels of nitrogen
15 that correlates with different levels
of carbon 14 so if you can compare the
two you can say here are the animal
bones let's call those hard carbon 14
dates and here are the human bones and
the human bones have slightly different
ones so what can we infer we can infer
from this the percentage of the diet
depended on fish and this is sort of a
revelation because fish bones do not
preserve archaeologically unless big big
fish but ordinarily fish bones don't
show up very much but it turns out that
there are societies such as around the
big rivers flowing into the Black Sea
the the Danube the de Nestor the did
yepper the dawn the Boog we're in the
early days of human settled society
fifty percent of the animal protein was
coming from fish not from hunting the
other fifty percent came from hunting
there were no domestic animals and of
course it applies to the Pacific
Northwest where he had huge elaborate
communities with possessions and ranks
of society and so forth but no farming
but lots of fish
I mean Hitchhiker's Guide to the gallery
to the galaxy was right on about thank
you for all the fish because fish are
terribly important so then you go back
to the question of Egypt and Mesopotamia
these early river valleys were they the
Centers of civilization because that is
where wheat and barley are grown as we
know because of the remains of these
Neolithic sickles or these are the
centers of civilization because that's
where the fish were
well of course at the time people were
doing their archaeological studies of
Egypt Mesopotamia they didn't know
anything about nitrogen 15 and so going
back and now trying to decide what sort
of role Phish played hasn't yet been
done but of course it leads to to the
possibility that you say that settled
society does not may not depend upon
domesticated plants though may depend
upon abundance of fish so communities by
lakes communities along seashores where
you often have a whole acres covered
with seashells from edible mollusks
rivers you might even say that areas
that have the fewest opportunities to
get fish that is to say deserts with
rivers running through them are more
likely to have dense human settlement in
those valleys than areas like Central
Africa where there are fish flopping
about all over the place from myriad
rivers and streams and so forth because
they get you know 30 plus inches of rain
per year in the Middle East gets and
most of it less than eight inches of
rain per year so you know what we've
written in our narrative assumes that
grain farming is the key and yet it may
it may not be the key and indeed
farming may not be the key and this
leads to something that I have been
perplexed by all summer long when I was
supposed to be writing a book
and this is the problem of the the grand
narrative we have that by growing wheat
and barley fields of grain we could have
a more dense population because the
calories per acre were greater if the
grew grain than if you were simply a
forager the broad estimate that is used
is that foragers require about one
square mile
per year to support a single person so a
foraging band of 50 to 75 people you can
imagine living somewhere within a circle
with a radius of about 5 miles and that
would be you know between 75 and 80
square miles and that would sustain that
band for the year and the next band of
57 that people would be at least 10
miles away and therefore you don't have
density of of settlement you just have
small dispersed bands but if you have
wheat and barley then you can have dense
settlement and then the theory is that
we have in this book and in all the
other books now once you have dense
settlement then you have division of
labor then you have social classes you
have trade you have cities you have gods
you have warfare and you have
civilization all because you can have
this density of a population if you have
wheat and barley but wheat and barley
are not really all that big on producing
calories per acre potatoes produce way
more calories per acre than wheat and
barley
so do yams soda sweet potatoes so does
manioc
so does rice so do apples
wheat and barley Oh their grass seed
they don't you know that they're edible
but but they're not really you know even
corn produces a lot more I mean sort of
wonder if could wheat have been grown
and trained to become like corn to be
giant so you just have an ear of wheat
leave it we never tried it but but then
the result is that if all of these other
plants that are domestic and are grown
in other parts of the world other than
the river valleys the Middle East if
they produce not only more calories per
acre than wild plants but they produce
more calories per acre than wheat and
barley and other grains then why didn't
civilization grow where those plants
were why didn't these things that we
associate with density of population
settlement arise in central Africa or
northern Brazil or places that where you
had these other plants growing no one
can answer that they can't answer it
because these other plants don't so far
leave archaeological remains whereas the
straw that is used for that wheat and
barley grow on comes to be used as a
strengthening item in early pottery and
you can identify Queen barley straw in
places where you've had burning the
carbonization of the of the kernels will
allow you to identify grains but no one
has a way of identifying the earliest
manioc or the earliest yams
and yet the foragers of South and
Central America and Africa and Southeast
Asia whores who still live by hunting
and gathering eat these things as wild
plants it isn't that the plants weren't
known so when did they become domestic
when did they start to support dense
populations why weren't they the first
and here you get you get mysteries like
let's take bananas the genus of the
banana moose has four species as I
recall three of which are not edible by
humans at least all bananas plantains
and bananas same thing are belong to the
same species and what is striking about
bananas is that the banana has no seeds
you can take a banana and stick it in
the ground and wait the rest of your
life and you will not have a banana tree
growing where you put that banana in the
ground there are no seeds nor is there
any evidence of their ever having been
banana seeds and yet the other species
of that genus all have seeds so at some
point selection of this particular
edible banana plant developed so
specifically in relationship to human
population that the only way the bananas
could be spread was by humans taking
cuttings from banana trees and sticking
them in the ground and they did this
around the world in prehistoric times
whatever that may mean
bananas produce enormous numbers of
calories per acre they'd be cut we know
that they're that they become domestic
very early because they lose their seeds
but we don't know how early because we
have no archaeological remains that
prove that could you have had
civilisation predicated on massive
eating of bananas well why not you know
fried plantains are at least as good as
oatmeal so but it didn't happen so it
leads to this question of historical
reasoning that says you know post hoc
ergo propter Hoke
you know civilization comes in the place
where you have wheat and barley
cultivation therefore it must be a
result of that cultivation we put this
in the in the world history textbook
repeated over and over again and there's
a strong likelihood that it is simply
not true now let me say one final word
going back to this question of world
history in general because of the this
evolution I mentioned at the beginning
of class from the k-12 educational
system rising up higher and higher
spiraling toward the pinnacle of
achievement and finally reaching
Columbia University as a result of this
the United States is the only place of
teachers world history at least in this
in this sort of a decentralized fashion
and it's becoming a peculiarity of what
America and historians do and something
that is very questionable from other
historical perspectives because if you
if you as I said if you're doing
American history what do you do for the
period before 1776 you have
to Dueling what if you're doing English
history you have lots of history before
1776 you can just take that island and
wring it out for thousands of years and
have more history
same thing with France or Slovakia or
you know Korea or something it was the
Americans that have found that found it
necessary to to embark on this on this
eccentric this.d central
program so to the degree that world
history is becoming a sort of
philosophical outlook and not simply a
narrative it's one that is going to
become a proselytizing one I think in
other words I think Americans are going
to try to sell world history to the
world in the years to come
and when they get around in doing that
my hope is that they will be writing a
lot better books than the one that
you're going to be reading this semester
and hopefully better books along the
ingenious lines posed by the author of
the book when he's taking his own work
to pieces so I'll see you on Thursday
how many graduate students are in the
room okay one two three four five six